how are you cube I'm doing fine so you
know it's funny I saw after LeBron comes
you post that carpool karaoke with the
with Corden I thought you did that last
Sunday but that was previous correct
you've done that months ago with LeBron
yeah yeah months ago I guess LeBron was
throwing our hints the whole time go
back much that he was coming and I guess
this is one of them but it was pretty
cool to do it and it was cool that it uh
it all worked out and it was great
reason to bring it back up so you think
him doing this carpool karaoke with you
is a little hint that he's coming to Los
Angeles cube I think so you know if you
think back it seemed like you throw out
a few little hints and you know it's
kind of cool so how many hints did you
think he would give me some more
breadcrumbs that you thought he dropped
doing I think he went to a summer league
Laker game maybe that's right he did not
sure walking out I think he threw up a
Big L walking out the arena
that's one few more he was listening to
one of my tracks going in to consider
Rena one time and it was it was an older
track it was uh pushing rhymes like wait
like man maybe he's uh pressing up on
his West Coast flavor you know well now
it is poppin there's no doubt about it I
mean where does you stand do you think
in the history of you rooting for sports
here in Los Angeles that LeBron is
coming here to join the Lakers where
does it rank for you oh man I remember
you know when we you know when I was
first getting into the Lakers and we end
up getting like Bob McAdoo and I'm like
wow
you know we at the point we need a score
like this and we get him and you know
Bob McAdoo and no joke
and then
I remember us you know once was when we
got shack it was crazy because it was
like you know the Lakers you know Jerry
Buss can do anything you know how you
can pull off anything and uh and getting
a barn to me is one of those moments
just like Joe this organization always
comes through for us fans even getting
Dwight and Steve Nash and going back to
Carl Malone and Gary Payton you know
even though those those didn't work out
those were still you know the Lakers
kind of coming through with their
tradition I command it how it was when
they got will and Kareem you know it's
just it's great that the Lakers always
you know can pull a rabbit out the Hat
but it you kind of hit on something
there cube that that you have to win a
championship to be considered in many
ways a true Laker I mean you even
mentioned there hey it was amazing to
get the mailman and obviously the glove
coming here based on their amazing
careers and there's nothing to take away
from their careers but they didn't win
here I mean that that so do you think
that LeBron in order to be an official
Laker despite all the greatness that he
does embody and and Amit needs to win
here in order to become a true Laker I
mean to be cemented in the heart of the
fans no.1 championship to me is
necessary but I mean he's gonna be a
Laker for four years at least and you
know we'll see you know how it turns out
but if he wins here it's a wrap
IceCube big three founded here on the
Rich Eisen show okay so you're up in
Oakland week three of the big three
tonight's okay are you gonna are you
gonna at some point maybe get out there
and shoot before the game just to check
out Oracle yourself like kick the tires
yourself before they get out there this
evening
maybe I might get up there you know if
guys aren't seating on the court I might
jump up there take a few okay but guys
are you know sitting around you know I'm
definitely not about to get in a way
okay and the four point shot just test
out that four point line yourself okay
so how is the league gone so far how has
it been different I guess for you
you're - now that you're just three
weeks into your - oh you know we're
getting into our groove as a lady we
only have 12 games under our belt
so this will be the 13th and I think
we're getting better game by game you
know we got great numbers you know
having over a million people watch us on
Fox and and having a you know Facebook
numbers you know and at almost 800,000
so you know we're doing great numbers
it's just build on that and keep keep
producing great basketball you know I
know fans are starting to get into the
league and get into know what the leak
and offer being live is has been
incredibly helpful and so we just want
to keep pushing and keep trending up as
they say mm-hmm any of Warriors may be
coming out tonight you reach out to any
of them to see if they're around - come
check this oracle this evening I haven't
reached out you know usually usually
players pop up I know we got my man too
short and a 40-day performance so okay
that might bring out you know some of
the Warriors or Raiders or that's right
49ers or try out to stay home well you
know it's basically Oracle you just need
to walk through one tunnel and you are
in the home of the Raiders it's just
right down the hall
cube literally yeah if the trick is
going there yesterday when I go to
Raiders game we take a bus and those
line is where we park our bus
yeah and I was like yeah you can go into
both arenas boom boom I'm like oh that's
that's sweet
you know we're usually going into the
Coliseum but this time we went into
Oracle yeah cool I remember one time we
were covering a game a Raiders game and
Deon leaves the our green room and he
starts walking down the hall I'm like
where you going he goes I think Oracle's
right down the road here and he walked
in and grabbed the ball and I must say
he made three consecutive threes and
then he just walked off because that's
prong that's the way he'll roll yeah
that's what you're supposed to do when
you make three in the roads close the
walk off he did so are you gonna leave a
note for Gruden are you gonna look even
find her just leave a little note form
and give him a little piece of advice
I said I said my advice to him hmm
is when a Super Ball for us this time I
see I see
yeah I like it so it's not simple like
do you have your stationery up there do
you have any cube stationery with you
because you should do that fine okay I
find it you know that'd be my stationery
dear coach groots win one for us and I'm
not Tampa win for him for us this time
sure when one fighter for the kuester
not to give her the cube stir they got a
pay khalil Mac first I think you yeah
don't they do that to pay the man pay
the man
it's another thing that do me okay well
hey look
Congrats on getting LeBron for the for
the home team here it's he's gonna run
this town essentially nights it's gonna
be incredible oh it's gonna be awesome
I'm gonna be up in there okay I look
forward to it and have a good night with
big three yeah check out the big three
man you know we on a 5 o'clock p.m.
I guess that specific time Pacific it's
like Eastern yep in the box
Big Five on the big people watch Empire
ok ok big Fox same one is Empire very
good and that's at 8 p.m. Eastern 5
o'clock Pacific and on face book at 7:00
Eastern and 4:00 Pacific always love our
chats will
take take take care of yourself cube
okay thanks I appreciate you man that
was always that's uh that's cute the
Rich Eisen show weekdays at noon eastern
on audience